[Music]
I still believe your fever
[Music]
your holy word
don't Jeremy
come here
no way
it's a gift from all of us how did you
afford this they took out a loan and we
all agreed to no Christmas gifts this
year we worked it out yeah you got to go
for me music is a hobby
for you it's a gift
so go right here story
you know I want you to know that
whatever this is and wherever it takes
us that I'm with you every step every
moment I'm with you I'm in I'm so near
and uh yeah you know I figure if we're
gonna get married we have a lot to talk
about
yeah
I love you I do madly so marry me if
what are you doing tonight tonight
it depends there's lots of stuff I could
be doing really a lot of things okay
well if you find yourself free at a I'll
be at the beach Oceanside Pier you got
you know step on by today what no that's
not a but only because you literally
just asked me out just right over here
we'll see
and you should you shouldn't you should
bring your guitar as well okay today
[Music]
Hey
I thought about it all night
actually and okay okay yes okay one date
Oh yep okay yeah all right I mean okay
okay
by your daughter well you asked me to do
a play for us oh no all right guys we've
got Jeremy camp here all right find me
in the river
I mean
walked against the water
now I'm waiting if you please
[Applause]
[Music]
if the class season
[Music]
we're going to be held what if I'm not
supposed to be healed
[Music]
you chose to walk into the fire with her
that's what love is
[Applause]
he's at 4 o'clock
4.5 million
let's welcome charity camp
[Music]
fear
[Applause]
[Music]